die leise hat sich im laufe der jahre
verändert
er hat sich aufgegeben er bekommt starke
sedativa aber dafür gibt es einen grund
er ist zu schlau für sie wäre es ist ein
bemerkenswerter schauspielerfilm in dem
drei höchst prominente akteure nämlich
james mcavoy bruce willis und samuel
jackson zusammen auftreten so weit ich
weiß das erste mal in ihrer karriere die
drei sind davon überzeugt besondere
fähigkeiten zu besitzen wie man sie aus
comic büchern kennt ich habe für diese
art störung eine wirksame therapie und
jeweils in ihren rollen auch unglaublich
spaß machen zuzusehen und trotzdem ist
es ein film der einen zuletzt ein
bisschen unbefriedigt zurück lässt meine
kopfhörer wieder mal an weil jemand der
für seine tour ist ganz klar das heißt
seine filme musste man immer mit rechnen
dass fünf bis zehn minuten vor schluss
ein faktum vorkam was alles hat was man
vorher gesehen hatte plötzlich noch
einmal umdreht und eigentlich die
handlung in ganz ganz neues licht
gesetzt
das klappt diesmal überhaupt nicht weil
es nicht gut vorbereitet ist dann denkt
man ja gut und das ist eigentlich
überhaupt keine überraschung von dem
mann sind wir ganz andere
ich muss hier raus kommen bevor er es
tut sie können hier nicht raus
immer unterschätzen sie das das geht nur
sollte man auf keinen fall meiden denn
natürlich macht es viel spaß bruce
willis in einer wirklichen alters kralle
zu sehen und da macht er auch überhaupt
keinen hehl draus also wie der mit
seinem grauen bart dadurch läuft das ist
schon bemerkenswert viel sagend oder
nicht aber dass wir auftritt ist schon
richtig schön terminal jackson es immer
sein geld wert der spielt natürlich auch
seine rollen ziemlich immer ähnlich
angelegt aber da kommt man ja gerade
spaß und gut ich bin nicht der größte
fan von james mcavoy wenn es außerhalb
der ex filme sich abspielt aber auch der
ist hier zumindest besser als in split
als der persönlichkeit gespaltene
mädchen entführer
so gesehen wirklich drei sehr
bemerkenswert zu verfolgende
schauspielerleistungen die einem spaß
machen beim zusehen
darüber hinaus sollte natürlich jeder
der überhaupt an schirrmanns filmen
gefallen hat es sich einfach deshalb
ansehen und zugucken wurde sich hin
entwickelt denn den muss man immer
wieder zutrauen irgendwann mal das ganz
große comeback zu schaffen nur das hier
ist es noch nicht
also nicht meine hand und lassen mich
heraus marschieren
[Musik]